And one policy, that tries to more
closely approximate the PLRU is the so
called pseudo PLRU policy.
So it's really trying to
approximate the PLRU but
sometimes it doesn't exactly match it.
So let's look at an eight
way set associative cache.
And with a pseudo LRU policy
what we keep is one bit.
Per line in the set, so
in an eight place set associative cache,
we will have a one bit
associated with each line
as opposed to three bits that we
would need for our LRU counting.
So how does pseudo LRV work?
All of the bits start at zero and
what we will do is,
every time a line is accessed,
we will set its bit to one.
So for example,
this one becomes one, this one becomes
one, then this one becomes one.
As long as there is at least one
zero bit here, we keep doing this.
And if we ever need
to replace something,
we pick among the blocks
whose bits are zero.
So all the recently accessed blocks
will have the bits at one and
thus safe from replacement.
Eventually, however, if we have
a lot of hits, so for example,
in this particular state, we will pick
the least recently used block because it
is the only one that has a zero bit.
Eventually however,
all of the bits will be set.
So evnetually we will
have this become one.
And now, we cannot replace anything.
So we detect the situation where
all the bits have become one.
And when we set the last zero bit to
one, we zero out the remaining bits.
So now,
we have state that is similar to what
not most recently use would tell us.
We only know what was
the most recently used block.
For the rest of them,
we need to pick it randomly if
something needs to be placed.
But as we start accessing some other
blocks, we get a better idea of
which ones are the more, and
which ones are less recently used.
So at any given point in time the pseudo
LRV policy is somewhere between
the NMRU and the LRU policy.
We have seen that when one bit is set
we are effectively
implementing the NMRU policy.
When more than one bit is set.
But not,
almost all of them were in between and
when all but one are set,
we're implementing the true LRU policy
because we know exactly which one
block is the least recently used.
So, this policy behaves
somewhere in between LRU and
NMRU in exchange for using more bits.
But it's also very
simple because on a hit,
all we have to do is set the bit
that corresponds to the block.
Which can be done very quickly and
efficiently.
So as far as activity on a cache hit
is concerned, both pseudo LRU and
NMRU have much less activity than LRU,
which helps us with both power and
also hit time on the cache.